the third and final movie in the to all
the boys trilogy is finally here and
it's filled with incredible details from
cheeky kitty call backs and sweet treat
easter eggs to secret cameos
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and today
i'm revealing all the hidden adorable
references you missed in always and
forever
of course spoilers ahead if you haven't
seen it yet the movie kicks off with
lara jean writing to peter from seoul in
a cafe that looks like it's ripped
straight from the pages of a comic book
the amazing thing is that this isn't a
set but a real-life coffee
shop in seoul there's been deliberately
painted all white with black outlines to
create the illusion that you're in a 2d
cartoon named after its street number
the cafe is an incredibly popular
location especially for posting on
instagram
and the way it's used in the movie along
with some of the film's comic book style
transitions really reminded me of aha's
video for take on me which feels
especially fitting given lj's love of
80s pop culture
and another cute detail in the korean
cafe scene is that the postcard that
lara jean writes to peter
has the word soulmates on the front
pointing to the fact that even though
they're already thousands of miles apart
lj and pk are still destined to be
together i love you peter
always and for like a lingering fart or
nay
a bruise that never heals during lara
jean's make-believe montage of her
future life with peter after she
imagines getting into stamford she sees
herself
signing a book she's written called woe
woe woe this is a funny nod to peter's
catchphrase from the first movie
although fans didn't get any woe woes in
the second film this moment in the new
movie is a little tribute to the huge
sensation and meme those words from
peter became after the success of the
first film
another image we see in lj's imagined
future is her and peter painting their
home together
as lj watches on peter paints a big blue
heart with their initials in the middle
a moment which reminded me of how lj
painted a blue heart on a lantern after
their first real date in the second
movie
and those blue hearts in both films fit
perfectly with the trilogy's colour
palette
which relies heavily on cyans as well as
magentas and yellows
as we can see from the characters
clothes as well as the film sets props
and cinematography
and those signature colors magenta cyan
and yellow
are the same ones that the filmmakers
used to light the empire state building
for the new york rooftop party scene
when peter surprises the cubbies after
they get back from korea kitty
compliments him on his welcome home sign
your spatial planning could use a bit of
work but i appreciate the glitter
which is a nice nod to this moment in
the second movie where kitty used
glitter for the valentine's card she
secretly sent to mrs roth's child on
behalf of her dad
dad's not a glitter type of guy nor were
you a peter kavinsky kind of girl to
sprinkle some glitter on it genevieve
complimenting lara jean's footwear and
always and forever
oh my god cute shoes i like this it's a
call back to how jen commented
sarcastically on lj's boots in the first
movie
cute boots thank you so much for your
service
notice how lara jean and genevieve's
position in the hallway has been
switched around this time
making this moment a mirror of the
original scene and showing how they are
both back to being friends now
rather than the antagonists they were at
the start of the first film
author jenny han's cameo in each of the
movies has become a tradition
and in always and forever she makes a
brief appearance in the flashback scene
of lj and pk's meek cute
han is principal cho who calls lara jean
on stage to receive an attendance award
according to the filmmakers her
appearances as a middle school principal
in the first and third movies
and as alder high's vice principal in
the second movie give her
character a mini career arc across the
trilogy
by the way the same crying girl that
jenny han was comforting on valentine's
day and p.s i still love you has a much
happier moment in always and forever
when she's the recipient of a musical
promposal molly marshall will you go to
prom with me
yes of course when lj organizes a
perfect date with peter she takes some
inspiration from the classic koen
brothers crime comedy the big lebowski
and plans an evening at a local bowling
alley where she sets their table with
some tasty treats for them to eat
including the same kind of fruit
turnover she made for peta as a
valentine's day gift in the second movie
when lara jean is planning the perfect
date she compiles a list of some of
peter's favorite films for ideas
it's mostly made up of action movies
like fast and furious but an interesting
one is x-men apocalypse because that's
the film in which lana condor made her
acting debut as the mutant jubilee
this is scott he's new here too
and this might be a little stretch but
the movie this is the end has been
crossed out
perhaps foreshadowing that although
always and forever is a final movie in
the series this won't be the end of lj
and pk's story
as they choose to stay together at
university despite the many miles
between them
owen doctor's sleep appears on the list
as the director of the second and third
to all the boys films michael ferminari
was the cinematographer on that movie
butterflies keep cropping up in the new
film from the poster and lara jean's
english classroom
to various knickknacks in her bedroom to
the ones on lockers at school
culturally butterflies are often symbols
of transformation
freedom and new beginnings all themes
that are crucial in the final film
as lara jean is on the verge of a new
life making big decisions that will take
her from her final days as a schoolgirl
to her new future as a university
student
which is why we also see a large
butterfly poster as well as a follow
your heart poster in margot's college
room in scotland as she's already making
her own life for herself and encourages
lj to do the same
as well as butterflies pointing to the
theme of change in lj's life the film is
full of posters that foreshadow her
decision to choose new york university
over berkeley
even before lj knows that she's been
accepted to nyu
at school there are new york posters
with the statue of liberty all around
peter
and as they all hand in their permission
slips for the east coast trip
we see posters including one with the
words how far will you go
a drawing of a woman with a question
mark over her head signaling how lj will
question her decision about university
and a poster of another woman with the
words own your story which feels
especially fitting because as lj's dad
later tells her
listen laura jean you gotta stay true to
yourself you can't save this
relationship by not growing
likewise when lj's struggling to decide
whether she should follow her desire to
go to nyu
and asks jen whether she should go she's
standing next to posters that feature
the statue of liberty
the words do what you love and you are
stronger than you think
the fabric box that lara jean fills with
memories of their relationship and gives
to peter
is actually the same box that held lj's
letters to all the boys she'd loved
before
which gives the box extra emotional
value because it was instrumental in how
lj and peter's relationship began
after laura jean accidentally texts
peter that she got into stamford to
celebrate he turns up outside her house
recreating the iconic scene from say
anything the 80s rom-com where the male
lead holds up a boom box to prove his
love there's this great scene with john
cusack and he sits underneath the window
and he holds up a boom
lara jean's love of classic 80s movies
has been a hallmark of her story in this
trilogy from her recreation of the
opening scene of adventures in
babysitting at the beginning of p.s i
still love you to the rule she made in
the first movie that peter could put his
hand in her back pocket an idea taken
from the opening scene of 16 candles and
she acknowledges this in her closing
monologue of this movie
my whole life i've wanted the kind of
love you see in the movies
boombox over the head hand in the back
pocket of your jeans kind of love
at the beginning of the movie we see
lara jean reading pride and prejudice
and the film also draws attention to her
packing the classic novel for her trip
to new york
as a romantic comedy of manners it's
clear why pride and prejudice would
appeal to lj but i think the book is
also alluding to how she
and peter both grow and mature in their
relationship throughout the final film
and trilogy as a whole
similar to how the main protagonists in
jane austen's novel work to overcome
their flaws to ultimately achieve a
happy romantic union will you dance mr
darcy
not if i can help it do you dance mr
kavinsky
not if i can help it and the repeated
pride and prejudice references may also
be a little nod to jenny han's third
book in head trilogy
where lj creates a mood board featuring
the pride and prejudice movie for her
dad and trina's wedding
oh and let's not forget the lj's sister
kitty aka catherine
i'm katherine that was weird it's not my
name kitty well
i mean catherine's kind of my name but
if you don't call me that call me kitty
you can call me whatever shares her name
with one of the characters in jane
austen's
famous novel laura jean's love of harry
potter and the original books was
touched upon in the second movie in a
flashback scene where she's reading the
prison of azkaban together with john
ambrose
and harry potter comes up again in the
third film but it turns out that lj's
sister kitty is also a huge pot ahead
and she's outraged to discover her
korean boyfriend hates it
he said and i quote that it's so
dumb how am i supposed to be in a
relationship with somebody thinks it's
the greatest literary achievement of our
time
is dumb and if you want to discover all
the easter eggs and incredible details
you missed in p.s i still love you as
well
tap here to watch that video or follow
the link in the video description
so what did you think of always and
forever did you like the ending and were
there any other interesting details you
noticed
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video then
i really appreciate a thumbs up
tap left to watch my next netflix video
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers